you
hi everyone is Jerry this is a round
four game from the 2017 Norway chess
tournament between Levon Aronian playing
on the white end and our current world
champion Magnus Carlsen this game was
played today June 10th and many have
already pegged it a brilliancy so let's
dive right in and see what made this
game so special d4 d5 Slav defense this
turns into a semi Slav III a6 b3 Bishop
to b4 what's going on here we have a
piece that is not only unprotected
but pinned in such cases it's usually
very important to not only protect the
unprotected but also break the pin
Bishop to d2 satisfies those two
conditions doing otherwise allows black
to pile up on the pinned piece Knight B
to d7 and de Bishop to d3 observe some
central squares Kings are now tucked
away Queen e7 and a mysterious move
follows for me at least I cannot quite
put my finger on her own Ian's 10th move
Bishop to c2 so what do I say call it a
high-class waiting move and move on well
I'll leave this open to you I need some
help with this I just don't know the
deeper points behind Bishop to c2
initially I was going to add well in the
event of an e5 break light does not
necessarily have to now react to a
potential fork with E 4 but I think that
that is too shallow a description
shallow a point there's something deeper
going on here that I again just cannot
put my finger on the reply is rook to d8
Carlsen by the way was likely taken
back by bishop to c2 is well spending 17
minutes on his reply so he was probably
trying to work out the points behind
bishop to c2 as well let's see how play
follows a3 what is going on with a three
well let's find out that's it that's a
pawn isn't it
Carlson takes it and now we have rook
takes Bishop Queen takes rook c5 let's
hang out for a moment what just happened
here
what did Aronian eat today White has
given up a pawn White has given up the
exchange what does white get in return
let's see white has a little bit of
space when it has a pawn in Black's
house and the more important feature the
black queen she is vulnerable she is
very close to being trapped going to be
for going to a5 those aren't safe
squares this allows Knight takes d5 with
the discovered attack black needs to be
very careful black needs to make some
concession now in order to free the
black Queen from this Queen side area
where there are a lot of white minor
pieces that are just a moment away from
attacking her b6 prying open the Queen
side a little bit b4 Queen takes b4
Knight takes d5 and now the follow up
move Knight to e4 move 14 just to
highlight how dangerous it is for the
black queen playing a quiet move like
Bishop to d7
well now the knight goes home the Queen
has three options and the bishops will
soon be excited about controlling those
three squares something like this cooked
queen in the corner
so black has to act fast and does so
dropping a knight in the center this
comes with a cost
you know Knight takes Knight to e4
ensures that the Queen will not be
trapped because one of the T's to white
minor pieces will be exchanged now
Knight takes Knight pawn takes Knight
Bishop takes pawn white picked up a pond
from that sequence white is still down
the exchange but it's still the case
that the Queen is offside she's not
going to be trapped but she's out of
play there's no other black piece that
is tied in well with her she's all on
her own specific to this sector of the
board
continuing we have rook to b8 one of the
better moves in this position is Knight
to f6 you'll see why soon enough black
plays rook to b8 this Bishop is a really
strong piece in the center after rip to
b8 we have another investment black
gives up some more material sacrificing
now in h7 the Greek gift sacrifice on
board luring the King out Knight g5 by
the way just to give you some insight
here these next 12 moves
Aronian basically turned into stockfish
i don't know what he ate today but about
these next uh these next twelve moves
they're top moves
he played very well Bishop takes h7 King
takes Bishop Knight g5 the King go into
the eye of the storm
no he runs back to g8 going forward
allows these two pieces to give the King
a giant headache what's the idea here
there's discovered tricks the King goes
to f6 there's d5 and get mated and it's
it's no fun going towards the center
this is already a mating three by the
way
Queen f4 computer suggest Queen e3 if
you run here ball game it's no fun
going forward the best move is to run
away scared black does queen h5 lights
down a rook wide only has a pawn to show
for it but compared the quality of the
Queen's Queen on h5 White Queen on h5
compared with the black queen on 8th
Street yeah she is way out of bounds she
might as well be on I don't know what
rank would call that okay
struck at the Queen's looking to sneak
in here Knight f6 lone defender Queen
takes f7 King h8 Queen c7 look at this
path what's she doing now
striking at both unprotected rooks and
f7 square is now open for a fork Bishop
d7 9f seven rook is captured rook c8
clean takes b6 still guarding the knight
Knight to d5 the queen is now chased
away from defense of the night
clean a seven rip takes Knight e4 trying
to kick the night away so that Queen c7
can hit hitting both rook and Bishop
Queen d3 counter-attack pressure in the
pawn and the bishop on takes Knight
Queen takes bishop Queen c7 Queen g5
many only moves here 28 moves in now and
the game's over by moved 35 D takes c6
and after Bishop to ca yeah that is a
bishop that suffers from tall palm
syndrome what is he doing he's back home
but he's doing nothing and talk about a
very active Queen on c7 pressure on the
rook a spot on c4 White is no longer by
the way down material White has a
boatload of pawns
how many seven versus three so what kind
of imbalance are we working with it's
white has four pawns versus a dead
bishop tallip on
we get a little space for the king now
now that things have calmed down some
securing the king so that the group can
do some other exciting things this is
not a winning position for white but
life is certainly very difficult for
black compare the king positions whose
home is better f7g to our excuse me f -
G - h3 structure vs. g7 yeah it's kind
of difficult to find accurate moves when
your king is basically naked rook to d1
+ e5 is the one and only blunder of the
game better is to transfer the rook to
f8 observing the f2 point preparing to
meet rook to d3 this idea of a rook
lifts with Queen to e4 and if now rip to
g3 there's Queen takes d4 and black has
some pressure at least on f2 and more
importantly the Queen will be able to
defend against the g7 mate threat
black does not do this black does not
play rook to FA in this position instead
d5 trying to take advantage of the pins
pawn there is no D take C the rook is
hanging so after E 5 what do we have
rook to d3 pawn takes pawn and now a
very key move here Queen to e7 maybe
white wasn't excuse me maybe black was
anticipating rook to g3 immediately
threatening a mate this would not be
best let's see why
rook to g3 can be met with rook to g8
and after let's say Queen to e7 looking
for Queen to h4 there can follow Queen
takes pawn and now there is a reply of
Queen h6 on Queen to h4 what did white
play in this position instead of rook g3
white first plays Queen to e7 and
there's just no defense here Bishop f5
follows if rook to g8 is played here we
can have first Queen h4 the King now has
to move forward and this is just going
to be disaster there's already rook
takes d4 and you really don't have to
look any further
look at these two clowns here on c8 and
g8 and the king and he's just asking for
trouble so good luck team black it's
reading as a pawn and a half advantage
evaluation wisest evaluation is at 1.64
and climbing right now so there's little
resistance in trying this variation here
and well ends a bit more abruptly
actually the game move Bishop c5 or
Bishop to f5 is now met with rook to g3
mate threat on g7 and how do you defend
that Queen can't go too far by the way
she has a job it's not fun but she has
to babysit the rook here
and how else do you defend g7 bishop g6
if rook here that's the ballgame so what
is white put his black try here bishop
g6 the Queen still goes to h4 and the
game goes no further at this point
throws in the towel you can block here
but you lose the rook you can block like
this but now we have rook to g5 there
goes the bishop and you could run away
to g8 and well that simply drops the
rook the only thing to look at from this
variation is is this one past pawn going
to pose any threat well no after move
like d3 Queen f6 and how are you coping
with the mate threat on g7 you're not
pressure still on the rook the rook
cannot defend Queen f7 there goes the
rook there goes the pond and this is
easy enough but it didn't go that far
after this move 35 Queen to h4 Carlsen
once more throws in the towel what a
game
multiple sacrifices here first on the a3
square right right here move
eleven sacrificing upon sacrificed in
exchange cutting off the Queen black in
order to rescue the Queen needed to
invest some material and now another
sacrifice Greek gift a string of about a
dozen moves that are just perfect by
White Queen is a maniac hitting all the
black pieces a ton of pressure loosening
up softening up the softening up the
defense of the black pieces here and wow
what a game anyhow as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below let me know what
you think and as usual I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye